first of all there's no ads on this
video believe it or not this is not
about money for me Hillary Clinton I am
voting for Hillary Clinton
it's about fixing this problem with you
two now you're probably heard already
that youtubers are complaining because
their views are dropping significantly
now I know you're thinking oh boo tea
pot he already made enough money and now
he dares complain about this but this is
not just about me it's about smaller and
larger channel that are being affected
and the direction it's heading is very
concerning for the future of this
platform people won't believe me if I
say I really don't care about views and
making more money I care about reaching
my audience that the videos that I'm
working on the people who subscribe to
me can actually see them I really truly
care about that more I want to be clear
that technically overall views are not
being affected it's just on the newer
upload since about a month ago I feel a
huge responsibility to make this video
because not everyone has a voice on
YouTube
I know people might think well I don't
really care this does not affect me
youtubers are already making enough
money but it's still people's livelihood
at stake I think if this continues it's
gonna kill a lot of channels and trust
me I'm fine okay
I'll be fine but there are smaller
channels that are just barely getting by
all of a sudden 40% of their views are
getting cut out and they can't keep
making a living on YouTube which i think
is really sad and really stupid and a
mistake it's extremely frustrating not
being able to reach your audience with
my latest videos being record low I
don't know where and then you ask
YouTube hey what is the problem here
like something clearly changed and
they're basically saying no it's we
didn't change anything
there's been no algorithm change it's
you and then I'm like well it's not just
me it's so many youtubers talking about
this I'm not crazy
jacksepticeye the nicest person on the
platform he wouldn't be complaining
about this just because he wants to
complain he's complaining because it's
an actual problem it's a real thing
YouTube I promise now the thing is that
YouTube had a roughy
youtubers notice that complaining about
YouTube gets your views it's it's a
topic that people like to know about so
that I think people complain probably
more than they should and I realize that
now that there's there's actual
consequence to that because now that
there's an actual really important issue
YouTube is kind of closing in I - it's
thinking well they're just conspiring
against us again it's just one of those
things it's very concerning that they
are not taking this seriously now it's
been so much confusing fusion on what
the problem is no one seems to know I
think I know what it is so I'm gonna try
and explain it Oh on YouTube you hear a
lot of times about subscribing please
subscribe to my channel put it past 50
million but YouTube has really been
moving away from a subscription
time-based viewing experience for a long
time they want you to watch other videos
as well so basically what they replace
it with is let me show you if you
subscribe to someone and you watch their
content their videos will show up as
recommended or in this suggested thing
suggestion min [ __ ]
now most creators I'm gonna use the word
creator I don't know what the [ __ ] to
call it's [ __ ] youtubers most people
on the platform get half their views
from these two things this doesn't
matter if you're a small channel or a
big channel okay
so just to show an example on some
statistics here overall you see that I
get 30% of my views from suggested
videos that is not counting browse
feature which is homepage which is 53%
let's just ignore that for now let's
just focus on suggested because this is
I know this is a lot to take in
okay now suggested views I get 30% of my
views from that's what I'm noticed
got caught off I noticed my views are
dropping roughly that amount now if you
check an old video oh look I got 60% of
my views from suggested videos this
one's 62%
this one's 63% these were videos that
were uploaded in October now something
something 100% happened in November all
right because all the stuff we got
suggested videos zero point Sam
what and it's not just one video look at
this one
0.2 now this is a video that I didn't
make it was an animator Jay who worked
on this for like a month and we shared
the ad revenue and since this one did so
poorly compared to the other one so
seeing this I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on this is so clear that it's not
a prop that it's a problem but YouTube
saying hey Felix it's not a problem
because look your suggested videos are
still 30 percent even if you closed in
on the last 14 days look suggested
videos 32 they went up you should be
thanking us now from now on I'm just
gonna really just put our theories out
there okay let's just let that be clear
but it's suggesting older videos it's
something I've noticed at least if you
click on one of my newer videos it is
essentially suggesting ancient [ __ ]
videos like videos I did six months ago
which and you know what it's a good it's
a good idea but you can't completely cut
out the new ones putting them at 0.2
percent now what I think has happened is
that you these old videos has already
qualified to be as suggested videos but
now you need to qualify to show up as
suggested videos and what will qualify
is essentially videos with really high
click-through rate like videos that
people really want to click on really
fast and if you upload on a daily
schedule you're not gonna get that maybe
if you upload weekly you're not gonna be
affected by this at all where all the
views then I'm sure you maybe if you
haven't made it this far in the video
but you probably think well if Peter is
getting less views that's good I don't
like his continent way [ __ ] that guy all
right I get it
you don't like PewDiePie it's it's
really nice that you have to point that
out every time you're just talking about
PewDiePie every single article you don't
you don't like PewDiePie that's fine I
don't care okay what I noticed showing
up instead which you probably noticed as
well [ __ ] breast feed video this
video got 61 million views all the
sudden people see giant ass [ __ ] tits
in the sidebar and they're like oh mama
I'm gonna click on that gets a lot of
clicks keeps getting suggested I've seen
porn show up in the suggested feed which
is just insane how is that possible look
I'm watching gameplay
gameplay gameplay gameplay gameplay porn
[ __ ] porn look at this [ __ ] 18-plus
what the hell is happening to YouTube
this [ __ ] [ __ ] like 10 million views
B movie memes which you know I can
support but the rest just seems a bit
like this is really the content that we
want on the website so it seems like you
need it's more like focused on viral
videos somehow you have to have a really
really strong video for it to show up
and I think it it shows because I did
that I'm gonna delete my channel video
which really did really well and way
more than I ever expected it's like for
going from zero to 100 I just want to
find a middle ground you know now I've
talked I spoken to YouTube they've
acknowledged that this is a problem and
it's weird how this has changed
they haven't admitted they want to they
won't say if they did its intentionally
or not I would like to give them the
benefit of the doubt that this is it's
just a glitch and hopefully they can
work on fixing this as soon as possible
which is why I'm making this video to
strengthen that and making you guys know
what the problem is I really don't want
to spread false rumors and I don't want
people to get riled up I just want to
keep pressing YouTube on fixing this one
issue there are more issues as well with
subscribe subscription disappearing but
I think this is the main important one
to focus on right now I appreciate that
YouTube is working on this and trying to
fix this because it doesn't like I said
it just doesn't affect me affects
everyone on YouTube
I honestly thought you two was about
what content people the majority want to
watch but it seems like it's becoming
less and less of that it's not about who
you want to watch it's about who's gonna
yell the loudest if this is all
intentional and YouTube is focusing away
from creator based content and less
personality based well then don't be
surprised if personality start leaving
YouTube
you